hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled mass cytometry and vaccine
development
utility utility and considerations i'm
xavier gutierrez of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by fluidic
now before we begin i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
i now present today's speaker dr patrick
reeves
an instructor in medicine at harvard
medical school and a team leader
in the vaccine and immunotherapy center
at massachusetts
general hospital for a complete
biography on dr reeves
please visit the biography tab located
at the top of your screen
dr reeves you may now begin your
presentation
so thank you for the introduction very
much appreciated
today i'd like to take a little bit of
your time to talk to you about how
our group here at mass general harvard
medical school has been using
mass cytometry and some of the lessons
that we've learned in terms of vaccine
development
and how that might help those of you in
the audience that are considering
using it within your own programs
so very quickly i just want to first
give a little bit of a summary about the
typical
uh sort of assessment that would be done
for considering using
scitok when you're in your experiments
and then illustrate some of those points
by taking you through a data set that we
have generated as part of a
consortium-based vaccine development
program
so you know there are numerous
challenges in terms of
developing vaccine there's the
considerations around the vaccine itself
what you know what is the candidate
going to contain what sort of adjuvant
is going to need what sort of dosing
schedule is going to be required
and then you know the next consideration
is who's the population that needs to be
considered when designing this vaccine
what sorts of environmental
factors and what sorts of properties
does the pathogen itself have how
variable is it how quickly does it
mutate
and then when it comes to testing your
candidate vaccine what model system or
systems plural are you going to use to
assess
the capacity of that candidate vaccine
to elicit a sufficient immune response
and to determine its safety and then
finally
how are you going to determine the
efficacy and the durability of the
immune response that the candidate
vaccine
elicits and so through the course of all
those different challenges
the correlation between the different
immune responses that can be measured
then can be used to address each one of
those different challenges in their own
way
and so when looking to identify those
immune correlates
especially those that appear early so
that you can
find those individuals via the in the
experimental model or in a
trial that have responded well to the
vaccine
or to find early hallmarks of of those
individuals who have not responded well
there's a number of competing interests
that occur there's limitations
to the types of samples that might be
available to the volume of sample
that might be available and that starts
to become a constraint if there's
multiple assays being conducted and then
there's very practical considerations
about the storage of those samples and
the transportation from distal sites
and then once you have those samples in
hand
you have to consider how accessible the
different assay
systems might be not everyone
necessarily has access
to a luminex machine or to a site
off or to you know ready access to
something like rna-seq
and so those start to also be
constrained as well as
then the limitations of the assays
themselves
once you have all of that data and what
you've decided upon the assays that
you're going to use
another hurdle occurs which is then the
analysis of the data itself
and you know if you've used fairly
straightforward assays
then the app then the analysis of that
data is also fairly straightforward
okay for a few key populations and
cytokines if you're using code cytometry
you correlate that back to different
measured features
then if you have much more complex data
you have to do a qc you have to perhaps
do a batch correction
and then you might want to get into much
more nuanced statistical analyses to
find correlates
that are not just straight ahead group
assignment based assessments
and then finally embedded in all of this
uh is the need to consider things like
the animal efficacy ruling and potential
questions that come from the acquired
agencies for
ultimately for approval and the animal
efficacy rule is
not a straightforward problem to tackle
and especially when generating high
parameter data
the agencies are not necessarily
accustomed to seeing that and so
bearing those constraints in mind is
also important
so when thinking about the different
assays that one might employ when
interrogating their samples out from
aesthetic you could
think about it essentially on a
continuum from ease
versus cost and then hypothesis driven
so you're only measuring a few key
parameters
to an unbiased approach and by ease i
want to be clear that
i don't just mean the ease of conducting
the assay but the entirety of the assay
arc
so how easy is it to generate data to
analyze the data to reproduce it
right and similarly cost doesn't just
consider the cost of running the assay
it's also the time necessary to analyze
those data
the time necessary to set up the assay
and make it robust and reproducible and
so
if we look at this and this is not you
know super precise but you can consider
on the low end that things like eliza
and ali spot they measure
a relatively low number of features and
they give you a very discreet
output and then you know you can also
run flow cytometry now admittedly
photometry can be
just a handful of antibodies or now you
know with the latest machines
you can push it to quite a few or 20 or
more
and then moving on up you have things
like luminex and mesoscale
and scitops which can measure you know
dozens
literally of parameters and at the very
high end you have things like rna-seq
and mass spec which are entirely
unbiased
but requires substantial amounts of
resources and expertise to analyze this
data
and so you know the nice thing about
cyclops is that it sits sort of
at the nexus of this and it offers
quite a bit of information without
necessarily being onerous
and it on the other side though it does
require some thinking
and some planning more than perhaps you
would normally use on the maliza or
traditional plus cytometry approach and
so one of the major
considerations is when you have the
opportunity to use 40 or more
antibodies in a panel how do you design
that experiment
what sorts of things you're going to
want to measure and of course there's
the concrete hypotheses
and the things that you just have to
have that you know that the reviewers
and that agency is going to ask for
and then depending on how the experiment
has been set up and what sort of
historical information you may have of
primary data that may be available
things like rna seq data or sequencing
data might be informative
whether that's telling you about the hla
types that
are within a population or within a
sample set or telling you about
different cytokines or transcription
factors that may be
changed that you may not necessarily
have included
without that information and then
similarly you know illuminex are alive
today that can also tell you about
changes that may not have necessarily
been the first ones that you considered
i think the other thing to point out
here is that in the design of a panel
especially for things like cycle
where possible it's it's always useful
to choose
markers that are multifunctional
somewhat promiscuous
so that it gives you information across
a number of different populations
so once you've designed and validated
your panel and you're able to acquire
the data by
cytometry you know the next challenge
really comes in terms of the analysis
and there for our group we do first a
quick check on the qc of the data
and then we move directly into doing
both manual analysis for those those
hypotheses that we want to see
out early and then we move and at the
same time in parallel we start to
conduct some of the computation analysis
because those can take some time
on the back end from all of that thing
you wind up with things like immune
correlates
that can tell you about which
populations correspond to
particular measures of infection or
particular kinds of immune responses
and then you'll generate from that those
testable observations that you can come
back and test maybe an orthogonal
assay but also you you may will wind up
generating new hypotheses
and so it can become a bit of a loop
here but the point is to identify
what kinds of readouts you need to help
push your platform forward
so i think for us as i mentioned before
relatively speaking in
mass cytometry you can get a high data
density
for the sample volume and i'll talk more
about that in a moment there are
opportunities to mitigate
batch effects and take advantage of the
fact that the cytosk can be very very
consistent from cycle site to site two
things that are much more difficult to
achieve with traditional flow cytometry
another consideration
uh that was important for us was the
fact that fixation is
very much a part of the standard
workflow for scitok and
because uh the example that i mentioned
in a few minutes required that
that really was was very important
for those of you that are new to scitoc
you know it is worth pointing out that
the standard clones that are part of
your favorite flow cytometry panel
most of them if not all of them will
translate over nearly directly
to psychology you have to generate a
whole new class of antibody reagents
and then on top of that cytok does offer
additional
assets things like being able to run
phosphoflow across a number of different
targets whole panels the tetramers might
be available
the ability to analyze whole blood and
so on
so with all of that in mind now i want
to tell you about
a vaccination and challenge today that
we conducted
as part of a new program to
develop a vaccine for a bacterial
infection called
called coccygealo burnetti so cocktail
i don't expect is a bacteria that most
of you familiar with
i think the key things here to
understand that it's a very infectious
bacterial pathogen that's transmitted by
the aerosol route
and it's typically found in ruminants so
in good
shape and what we know from
mouse studies the relatively few that
have been done is that t cells are
required for control and the
b cells are dispensable now there is a
vaccine that is already out there
however that vaccine has its own set of
problems so it's a wholesaling activated
vaccine and in
some individuals it can elicit the
ideogenicity
so these people have adverse events
following vaccination and as a
consequence of that
the vaccine is only approved for use in
a limited basis in australia
however in the last eight to ten years
it's become evident as
military personnel from western nations
have been deployed into endemic areas
that there was a need for a new vaccine
because it's not feasible to
pre-screen an entire battalion of
individuals before they're deployed
and so we were one of several groups
awarded an opportunity to develop
a new vaccine candidate for cocktailer
so i'm not going to spend a lot of time
on this but i do want to point out that
it was part of the big consortium effort
where we needed to determine what
epitopes are
important for the immune response
against coxiella in both humans and
in the mouse model system and ultimately
the objective was to generate
a new epitope-based candidate vaccine
my team one of the principal responses
that we had was to evaluate
the response to the usual vaccine
in a mirroring model so that then we had
a baseline comparator
for the candidate vaccine so the study i
want to tell you about used
transgenic hla dr3 mice so these are
mice with a human mhc allele
on a black sticks background the study
took
four different bleeds from the same ice
it's the longitudinal stages chief leads
about 150 to 200 microliters of blood
per time point
and then we had two groups of mice those
that were vaccinated
and then those that were not and then
those two groups were subdivided
into challenged and not challenged this
was done
in collaboration with our friends at
colorado state
and also out from the study we measured
the usual sorts of things what kind of
antibody tyler was generated how much
splenomegaly occurred what sort of
bacterial burden
did those mice experience and what were
the histopath scores
from various different tissues
from the blood though we had this
challenge of the fact that everything
was being done
in the bsl3 and that at colorado state
they had to prepare the samples for us
and then ship them
here to possible and so
as i mentioned we had these very small
sample volumes we had to get them out
from the dsl3
and validate that those samples were
inactivated and that required a hard
fixation
of over an hour with four percent psa
and we found that that was adversely
impacting the performance of normal
fluorescence-based
antibodies and we also had this
challenge of interrogating
a large relatively large number of mics
across multiple time points
and so on the basis of all of that we
chose to use
scitok and looking at the data the very
first thing that we were able to do was
to just identify major immune
populations and then track them through
the course
of the experiment just asking were there
key changes
anything gross grossly observable that
was
different between the vaccinated and the
naive animals
but this is something that you could
also accomplish with a relatively
modestly sized autonomous panel so
then we wanted to try and extract more
information
out from this cytoplasm experiment so on
the pin on the right there you see the
antibody panel that we used
and i think in pragmatic terms the
number as the number of panel
sorry antibodies increase then the
number of plots by actually a plot that
you're going to have to investigate
grows exponentially right and so it just
wasn't feasible for us
to do manual analysis for every possible
parameter across
every mouse and every time point so we
turn
to the some of the tools that have been
developed and this list is constantly
shifting it seems like every week
there's a new wonderful tool out there
for computational assessment of cyclop
data
but i want to illustrate for you some of
the tools that we use to help
investigate the data that came out from
our experiment
so the first thing i want to show you is
a movie of a
from a clustering algorithm called
vortex and
in this movie you'll see just the cd4
and the cd8 t cells moving to opposite
ends of the screen and basically what's
happening here
is the profile of each individual cell
across all of those different antibody
parameters that you saw
is being used to move each dot
according to the measured features
so that similarly labeled cells
land near each other in the plot and
those that are dissimilar from one
another
land far away from one another and so
what you'll see here
is on the bottom left is where the cd4 t
cells are
and on the bottom and on the top right
is where the cd8 t
cells land within each one of those
clusters though
sits different colored groups
and those represent different subclasses
of cd4 and ctop cells
so how do we use this kind of
information so what we can do is take
that clustering information
and we can look at something called a
parallel coordinate plot where
in the background there in grey you see
the values from
all of the other clusters that were in
the assay
and then that dark line there is the
features of that particular cluster that
i'm illustrating for you there
and then on the right is the frequency
of that cluster
in each individual mouse in that
experiment
and then underneath is the same but for
a different cluster so what you can
immediately see is that custom number
eight was enriched in the vaccinated
animals and
cluster number one was enriched in the
naive animals
and if you want to look more closely you
can see that they're both cd8 t
cells and that cluster 8 is positive for
y6c
cd73 and 62l
while cluster 1 is locking the
y6c and it has instead cd44
so immediately now you can start to get
into fairly granular assessments
so if we make a volcano plot of what the
differentially abundant clusters were
between the two groups we can see that a
number of different clusters come out
and you can take it one step further and
ask
okay on the just on the basis of
the abundance of each one of those
clusters what's the probability that any
individual mouse
as the as the abundance increases will
be assigned to either the vaccinated or
the naive group so basically here you
can see which
which clusters are the most important
for distinguishing the two groups
that's very useful however it makes it
very difficult
to look at the entirety of the
experiment
through all the different time points
and so to address that what we did is we
took
the various different clusters from all
the different time points and we've
divided them into t
cells b-cells and anatomy cells and then
we put them into a heat map and we asked
okay are there classes are there groups
of clusters that my hierarchical
clustering
are very similar to one another although
they're not exactly identical
and i won't walk you through all of
these but the point is we can break
each one of those major cell populations
into different subunits
and then we can take those different
classes and we can ask
any given time point which class of t
cells or which class of b
cells or innate cells were the most
important for determining
group assignment and then on the right
there what you can see is that for
each of the different classes of immune
cells
that were important how do they
distribute across the different groups
through time right so now we're able to
essentially get a sense of the dynamics
of these
important immune populations i think the
other thing to take away from this is
that we can see that
the diversity in the immune response is
already increasing by day 10 and at day
35 you have a fairly
diverse set of immune features that are
distinguishing the two groups
but that by day 44 which is two days
after we challenged
these mice that diversity collapses and
we have a very polarized immune response
that distinguishes the naive animals
from the challenged animals
and then even more so at the conclusion
of the experiment
a few days later
so that's useful to see uh
however you know that's it leaves a lot
of
granular information on the table and so
you're only looking at the changes with
these
large classes of immune cells through
time and it gives you a good sense of
you know major movements but it doesn't
really peel back
things down to the level of granularity
that we wanted so the next thing we did
was we
leveraged the fact that we had all this
phenotypic data how big did the spleens
get how much bacterial burden did they
have how much
antibodies header and for mouse by mouse
by mouse
we measured or we took the information
on the abundance of
every single cluster through the course
of the experiment and we've correlated
that
to each one of these phenotypic measures
and that's what you see on the right is
this
very complex correlation matrix
and so to avoid going cross-side looking
at this information
what we did is we made another
hierarchical distribution
of all of those different clusters and
we were able to break
that correlation matrix into different
modules
on the basis of essentially how similar
was the correlation
between the different cluster clusters
of immune cells
and that was independent of whether it
was a t cell or a b cell and an
immune cell if it correlated to this
phenotypic features in the same way that
it landed in that same module
even still with this it was difficult
for us so we took
[Music]
an approach where we repurposed disney
and rather than using the
phenotypes of the immune cells we use
their correlation features
to make a disney map to reduce the
dimensionality of this and to really
make it much more obvious
which of these modules and which subsets
of
or the contents of each module were
really the most important
in terms of the correlation and so
what i'm showing you here is the
correlation data as it relates to
antibody titer on day 10 and on day 35
and there what you see is essentially
the size and the
color intensity of each one of those
different shapes
it relates back to how strongly
it correlates either positively which is
red or negatively which is blue
to those measured features so you'll
notice that on the bottom left
those cells strongly correlate the
antibody titer on day 10 or on day 35
and not surprisingly those same cells in
the bottom left have an inverse
relationship
relative to how sick the mice got it so
how much effect bacteria did they have
in their swing how big did their sting
get what was the histopath score
for the spleen and generally speaking we
can see that that also holds true for
the liver and
for the lung although the heart got a
little
a little more complicated but then the
other thing that we could do is to take
those modules and say okay if we
essentially asked how strongly
does the module predict the vaccination
status
we can see that module 1 which is the
one on the bottom left there
unsurprisingly was the one with the most
predictive
value while modules four and five which
are those two in the upper portion of
the graph
were also very predictive but for the
opposite for those animals that were not
estimated so then
we could take that same piece of
information now and then
map back onto the under the disney plot
the individual clusters so previously we
were dealing with classes where
the clusters from each individual time
point
sort of combined together into a class
and here we've gotten
more granular so now it's each
individual cluster
on an individual time point now
mapped back and we can see that those
clusters that have
high predictive value for group
assignment are the same ones that are
landing
in the modules that we
found to be important for distinguishing
between vaccinated and naive
animals and as before we see that
there's quite a bit of diversity on day
10 and day 35 but the challenge really
induces a polarizing
change
so some of the things that as we
dig into that information unfortunately
i don't have time to go into all the
detail but we could see that a lot of
the features that were
shared amongst those different immune
cell populations
really came down to three or four
markers and those were live 6d
that which is the transcription
connector in cd73
and so we wanted to go back and manually
verify
this so using manual dating we then
went and get it out each of these major
immune populations and then asked
overall
does the abundance or the signal
intensity
change for those three key markers in a
way that agrees with what we found using
these computational tools
and the short answer is yes and
what was interesting about this though
is it revealed for us roles
for some of these proteins that we
hadn't really appreciated and that the
field
hadn't appreciated prior to that so it
now has opened up
a new set of questions about why why are
these
parameters being used by the immune
response as opposed to some of the more
canonical ones but it's also reassuring
to see that we could manually validate
our data i think the last thing i wanted
to show you was that given the
complexity
of all this data that we had generated
we needed a way to visually summarize
all of this and so we repurposed
something called a circus plot which for
those of you that are familiar with
genomics data
probably have seen this before whereby
on the inner wing
there you can see that the bacterial
burden
is what's determining the color and that
the dot
the height of that dot within the box is
how much
spleen the body weight change there had
been so how much splenomegaly did they
have
and then the next ring there with those
different
bars are the different histopath scores
for each one of those different organs
and then the the next ring out with the
dots
is the antibody tighter across the three
different days for which we measure the
antibody
and then the last two are the clusters
that we measured by cytok and i think
again the point of this was to visually
summarize and what you can see
is that the naive challenge mice and the
vaccinated challenge mites
look very very different from one
another but if you notice
animal number five within the naive
challenge group
in many respects it looks much more
similar
to the vaccinated challenged animals it
doesn't have that much bacterial burden
it didn't have that much
splenomegaly and the histopath scores
weren't all that high
you can see that very outermost portion
of the ring there
that immune cluster is lit up and that's
one of the ones that was one of the key
determinants
for the vaccinated mites distinguishing
themselves
so this is not something that
necessarily would have been easy for us
to pull out with
using any other visualization method
so to summarize as i said before we have
found
novel roles for cd73
tv and y6c and these different immune
populations
we could see information about the
dynamics about the fact that even by day
10 we could start to find
identifying features that distinguish
the vaccinated mice
from the naive mice and were predictive
of how they would do
following challenge
and so coming back to what i was saying
before i feel like
this experiment nicely demonstrates how
relative small sample volume under
somewhat austere conditions in the bsl3
where we had to get
samples out and fixed and verified that
they were decontaminated
we were still able to pull out quite a
large amount of
of information gained some new insights
and now we're able to use this immune
profile to grade the performance of our
candida vaccine in the same model system
so with that i want to say thank you to
all of the team and the collaborators
here
in particular to susan and the rest of
the team here within
the vaccine immunotherapy center and to
the collaborators at csu who made this
study possible
well thank you dr reeves for your
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar if you have questions you'd like
to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
and we'll get to it now let's get
started
our first question is how is adding in
phosphoflow markers to a panel helpful
in vaccine development
so i think that's a very interesting
question and certainly
the first instance where that comes to
mind is
phosphoflow is typically used to
interrogate innate immune responses so
rapid responses and so
here as in this case looking at
something like reactogenicity where
you're seeing adverse events i don't
know that
a priori you would want to design your
panel to have phosphoflow unless you
knew that there was a
key signaling pathway involved in in
your particular vaccination strategy
that i think is sort of a retrospective
analysis to understand
perhaps some of the nuances of a tox
screen or how to optimize adjuvanting
those things where you are looking at
the con the interface between the innate
immune response
and the adaptive immune response
phosphoflukin and ddp
pretty powerful
and how would using tetramers to id
antigen specific t
cells be helpful in your vaccine
research
so tetramers you know and one of the
major advantages of doing tetramers by
scitov is that you can screen
a large number of them simultaneously
and so here especially
in the context of dealing with
pathogen-specific responses
it's nice to be able to understand
whether or not your vaccine
is able to elicit both a broad and
specific
t-cell response and also you can ask
additional sets of questions about what
are the phenotypes of those antigen
specific cells
either following vaccination or
following challenge
and lastly i think bystander sorry uh
active bystander activation of
antigen-specific t cells for
other maybe related or similar
infections
is also an interesting component that
you would like to be able to know
so simply because a vaccine is eliciting
or challenges the listening response
it's difficult to specify which kinds of
cells those are actually
corresponding to unless you're able to
get down to the antigen specific cells
okay and looks like we're going to have
one last question here
have you applied the analytic approach
you showed here to human studies
right so this study as i mentioned
earlier in the presentation is part of a
larger consortium project
and in parallel there are human
analyses that have gone on and we're
expecting to be able to publish those
very soon
and this platform overall of analysis
has been
something that now we've we've turned to
something much more of a reproducible
unit that is the bedrock basically of
how we
march through most of our analyses both
for
immuno oncology and for vaccine
development
and it is worth pointing out that the
data that i just showed you was recently
accepted for publication and so all the
codes will be available made available
soon on github for those of you that
might want to
take some of the tools that we've
developed and make use of them
well thank you dr reeves do you have any
final comments for our audience
just thank you very much for the
questions and the opportunity to share
with you our work today and if there are
other questions that come to mind as you
think about the work
uh please don't hesitate to reach out
the team here would love to talk with
you
well thank you for thank you again for
your time and your
really important research we really
appreciate you uh
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed
on demand through july of 2021.
until next time goodbye